I don't understand why people are just
like Israel 110% everything about it all
the time and I'm just like bro I'm
sitting here in America like I don't
know why we're us is funding it us
provides funding to to Armenia did you
know this is insurgencies have been
going on in Myanmar since
198 and there's several hundred, dead
since then and this year alone I think
it's been
twice there one US politician or
corporate media pun who goes on TV and
uh no I agree that's the point the point
is like why why is it because we're
responsible for it and because the the
Injustice you figure out a way that
we're responsible for mean Mar too I'm
sure that we had our hands in there
somewhere all I'm saying is like we need
to get back to America First and I'm
sure at the bare minimum like there are
many people who I see are like very
critical of Israel and I'm like I don't
know what that's all about and I don't
want to get into a moral argument should
the US stop funding everything outside
the United States and go back to
securing its borders building up jobs
here helping the working class